e
s'appelle daniel clark bouchard et on
parlait des athlètes depuis le début de
l'émission qui ont ils doivent bien sûr
être discipliné l'effort des vertus que
connaît bien ce jeune daniel claque
bouchard donc jeune pianiste il a 14 ans
je vous le rappelle est il doit
consacrer de longues heures à son
instrument tout en jonglant avec sa vie
d'écolier pascal harrison julien a passé
une journée avec lui il y a de la
fébrilité dans l'air à l'école jacques
brel dans l'ouest de montréal
les élèves du secondaire met la touche
finale à leur projet d'expo sciences
parmi eux daniel claude bouchard
le pianiste qui vient tout juste de
fêter ses 14 ans a connu une année
chargée
une sortie d'album des concerts et de
multiples apparitions à la télévision
sans oublier ses travaux scolaires il
veut comme ses pairs épater les juges du
concours qui était comment les plantes
sont réagissent aux musiques dans la
musique et dans dc avec la musique et la
grosse différence c'est important de
savoir que la musique peut influencer
d'autres choses belle juliette hurel
après l'école direction conservatoire de
musique sur le plateau mont-royal
adapter les pièces musicales à sa
personnalité
c'est ce qu'il aime le plus j'attends
que lui on dit j'ai toujours une
différente façon de jouer est différente
de penser que j'ai quelques heures plus
tard il enfile complet et noeud papillon
ce soir là daniel bouchard est invité à
jouer devant un public de la petite
bourgogne où il troque la musique
classique pour le jazz on va voir le
film de occupé la scène et 110 en reste
respecte et je mens je serai l'invité
spécial
jouer devant un public c'est sa
récompense
même tard un vendredi soir après avoir
passé toute la semaine à l'école en leur
rêve
mon plus cher c'est de faire une tournée
mondiale ou d'aller sur l'aller mais
avant de quitter pour new york los
angeles londres où l'espace le jeune
pianiste caresse le projet de faire sa
première tournée sur le territoire
québécois
ici pascal harrison juliet radio canada
montréal